hey guys and happy end of the weekend -
now you know I'm not really a box office
grosses kind of person I leave those
videos to other more qualified
individuals but as it turns out this
weekend's box office is rather special
because the Avengers broke a couple
records actually The Avengers is now the
king it holds the record for the movie
with the highest-grossing opening
weekend and it made over 200 million
dollars say I'm gonna talk about that
because that is worth talking about all
right I love the fact this movie has
made this absurd amount of money in one
week two hundred million dollars most
movies don't make that in their entire
run of the movie theaters Avengers did
it in three days and I love this for the
fact that it sends a bit of a message to
the studio's I think you know a lot of
times the studio mindset is here let's
just crank out the movie doesn't matter
if it's good as long as we make a few
million bucks it's all good but the
Avengers has shown everyone that if you
take half a decade to make your movie
come to fruition you take your time you
do it well you make it right it'll pay
off for absolutely everybody the fans
will love it and you the studio will get
your money I imagine this will lead to
more movies being released
internationally first I mean the studio
is probably gonna look at the numbers be
like alright it was released
internationally it made a ton of
money over there everyone in America got
slacked it was released in America
everyone dumped 200 million bucks its
opening weekend just saying numbers of
numbers you know he's kicking themselves
about this as Fox you know they're like
just Whedon used to be our guy he did
two shows with us and now he's gone I
could just smile at the fact that
someone at the Fox Studios kicking
themselves and this makes me think of
one other movie The Dark Knight Rises
because apparently 9 out of 10 things
that happen in the summer movie season
are gonna make me think of that movie
before I got news of the Avengers
opening in two hundred million dollars
worth of style I would have said The
Dark Knight Rises gonna be the biggest
movie of the summer now I'm like I mean
let's look at the Dark Knight's opening
the Dark Knight opened huge but it did
not make 200 million bucks and there are
a couple things to consider one the Dark
Knight features the most iconic Batman
villain of all time the Joker
Dark Knight Rises doesn't really have
that it does have everyone who saw the
Dark Knight who probably wants to see
The Dark Knight Rises now and - is gonna
make me sound like a dick but it's just
the reality of the situation the actor
who played the most iconic Batman
villain of all time died before the
movie came out I'm not saying it's a
good thing I'm saying it's a complete
tragedy that it happened I'm just saying
that led to more people talking about
the Dark Knight that makes for publicity
but also
Dark Knight Rises is not being released
in 3d thank God
but 3d tickets do cost more Avengers
how's that going for it also so these
are the things you should probably think
about when you're thinking about what's
gonna make more of this summer Dark
Knight Rises are the Avengers and that's
my question to you guys what do you
think is gonna make more money Dark
Knight Rises or the Avengers and you can
even break it up you're like oh well I
think this is gonna make more in the
weekend but I think this is gonna make
more long-term you can cheat like that
if you like I won't hold it against you
comment below let me know and there's
always even like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]